und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend der
Kanzler hatte sich zum Thema
heizungsgesetz eigentlich ziemlich
deutlich geäußert für seine Verhältnisse
und Tempo angemahnt auch der
Fraktionschef der Kanzlerpartei Rolf
Mützenich wurde gestern mehr als
deutlich für seine Verhältnisse als er
bekannte er sei genervt dazu gleich noch
ein Gespräch mit ihm die FDP aber zeigt
sich wieder vom einen noch vom anderen
beeindruckt die 24 Stunden die Mütze
nicht aufzählte sind abgelaufen das
Gesetz ist heute nicht die ursprünglich
geplant in den Bundestag gegangen und
Buchwald berichtet
Christian Lindner hält Kurs zumindest im
Hamburger Hafen der Minister am Steuer
einer zollbergasse mit dem schönen Namen
Kehrwieder offizieller Besuch der Zoll
untersteht seine Ministerium und vom
Parlamentarischen Streit um das
heizungsgesetz will der FDP-Chef nichts
wissen es liegt im Deutschen Bundestag
ich bin ja nur Regierung
im Parlament jedoch besonders in der
FDP-Fraktion bestehen erhebliche
Vorbehalte gegen das Gesetz schlecht
gemacht so heißt es hier vor allem aber
zu teuer für die Bürger
es muss am Ende ein praktikables und
bezahlbares Gesetz sein und was keinen
Sinn machen würde ist horrende Kosten
auszulösen bei den privaten Haushalten
die dann der Steuerzahler wieder
ausgleicht die Grünen typiert sie
wollten das ebenso umstrittene wie
unpopuläre Gesetz möglichst schnell
durchs Parlament pauken im Herbst sind
Landtagswahlen entsprechen sauer die
Fraktionschefin
mir ist die FDP und vielen von uns
sicher
in der Vergangenheit immer bekannt als
ehrlicher Kaufmann
das gilt jetzt offenbar für Christian
Lindner nicht mehr der Zorn der Grünen
entzündet sich vor allem daran dass die
FDP-Minister dem Entwurf im Kabinett
zwar zugestimmt anschließend aber per
Protokollerklärung weitere Beratungen
verlangt haben Minister Habeck verärgert
ich glaube das ist hier eher darum geht
die
Zusage treu sind Verabredungen in diesen
runden
handfester koalitionskraft für die
Opposition ein gefundenes Fressen dieses
Gesetz das muss jetzt zurückgeholt
werden und nicht nur diese Woche es muss
zurückgeholt werden und dann muss die
Bundesregierung ihre Hausaufgaben machen
und ein vernünftigen sozial ausgewogen
und vor allen Dingen auch realistischen
Plan für die wärmewende ausarbeiten und
dann können wir weiter reden
die Bundesregierung vor allem der
Kanzler hält sich bisher jedoch bedeckt
zu Unrecht findet die Union und verlangt
eine richtlinienentscheidung der
Bundeskanzler muss jetzt hier wirklich
zeigen dass er die Absicht und die
Fähigkeiten hat die Bundesregierung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu führen das
was hier passiert ist seine
Verantwortung viel hängt nun von der SPD
ab vor allem wohl vom Geschick ihres
Fraktionschefs Rolf Mütze nicht
Vorbehalte gegen das Gesetz gibt es auch
in seiner Fraktion eine neue Balance
finden in einer schwierigen Koalition
der Mann ist gar nicht zu beneiden
und SPD-Fraktionschef Rolf Mützenich ist
uns zugeschaltet aus Berlin guten Abend
Herr Mütze nicht guten Abend pro Slomka
gestern da gab es ja quasi noch Hoffnung
dass das Gesetz dann heute doch in die
erste Lesung geht da haben Sie gesagt
Sie seien genervt wie genervt sind sie
heute gibt es da noch eine Steigerung
nein es geht nicht um Steigerung sondern
ich habe der FDP signalisiert dass ich
mir vorstellen könnte dass man in den
letzten 24 Stunden seit gestern durchaus
eben einen Gesetz auch in die erste
Lesung bringt man muss eben wissen der
Bundestag behandelt Gesetze in erster
Lesung um dann mit seiner Fachexpertise
Verbesserungen und ein besseres Gesetz
auch vorzunehmen und das ist unser
Interesse aber wir können es auch das
ist zwar schwieriger in den dann darauf
folgenden drei Sitzungswochen bis zur
Sommerpause noch schaffen wenn alle dazu
bereit sind und auch vernünftig und
unterstütze jetzt nicht mehr dass sowohl
das die bitte das Kanzlers auf Tempo zu
drücken als auch ihre ja doch sehr
deutlicher Aussage dazu von den
Koalitionspartner den Liberalen so
ignoriert wird
naja stören ist etwas übertrieben ich
finde es etwas ungewöhnlich dass man
sich weigert ein Gesetz was ja das
gesamte Kabinett beschlossen hat für den
Deutschen Bundestag eigentlich gar nicht
in die Beratung zulassen will eigentlich
macht man das nicht sondern man berät
und guckt dann was man an diesem Gesetz
noch zu verändern hat offensichtlich
will die FDP was verändern wir ja auch
wir wollen insbesondere uns um die
sozialen Themen kümmern das ist ganz
wichtig
ist ja auch um ihren Begriff
aufzugreifen dass man schon 30 Stunden
Koalitionsausschuss Marathon hinter sich
hat und da stand es dann eigentlich
schon und dann eine Kabinettssitzung
Unterstand dieser Entwurf dann auch und
jetzt nicht würden sie sich Robert habe
ich anschließen der sagt das ist
eigentlich ein Wortbruch
ich verstehe jeden Fachminister der um
seinen Gesetzentwurf kämpft er hat ja
auch dafür die Stimmen der FDP Minister
bekommen ob das ein Wortbruch ist das
würde ich so nicht sehen sondern am Ende
kommt ja es bei der Bewertung darauf an
ob wir das Gesetz im Deutschen Bundestag
beschließen in den Bundesrat muss es
dann auch noch aber ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir am Ende ein
gutes Gesetz zusammenführen werden
Zuversicht ein Ehren aber wenn man sich
dieses Hickhack und hin und her und
diese Streitereien anguckt kommt man
glatt auf die Idee kommen der
Sozialdemokratie ging es eigentlich in
der großen Koalition mit der Merkel CDU
besser als jetzt jedenfalls wenn es
darum ging sozialdemokratisches Profil
zu zeigen ich muss sagen ich habe ein
langes Gedächtnis und ich kann mich gut
daran erinnern was auch in der großen
Koalition nicht möglich gewesen ist oder
was sozusagen eben erst im letzten
Durchgang dann besser gemacht werden
konnte ich kann mich nicht beschweren
als wir den Mindestlohn eingeführt haben
wir haben andere Dinge auf den Weg
gebracht aber wenn es genau um die Frage
jetzt einer guten Arbeit einer auch
Klimapolitik geht wenn es um
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer geht
dann fühle ich mich in dieser Koalition
sehr gut aufgehoben na das Problem ist
so ein bisschen dass man den Eindruck
hat diese Koalition macht vor allem
damit Schlagzeilen dass die Grünen
möglichst viel Klimaschutz wollen und
die FDP möglichst viel von dem was die
Grünen wollen blockiert und die SPD ist
irgendwie so ein bisschen der beißt der
zuguckt aber wo ist das große
sozialdemokratische Projekt ich frage
das natürlich gerade auch heute an dem
160 geburtstag ihrer Partei in der Tat
und ich glaube wir haben gerade auch im
letzten Jahr gezeigt dass wir auch
Strukturveränderungen machen ich habe
gerade die Mindestlohn angesprochen das
Bürgergeld wir haben die Zahl der
wohngeld-empfänger erweitert und was wir
gemacht haben um auch die Kinder
Grundsicherung also die Bekämpfung von
Kinderarmut vorzunehmen für jedes Kind
den gleichen Beitrag ab dem ersten Kind
von 250 Euro durchgesetzt ich finde das
ist schon etwas und da zeigt auch die
sozialdemokratische Handschrift auch vor
dem Hintergrund von 160 Jahren
Sozialdemokratie wo wir uns nicht zu
entschuldigen haben und nie auch unseren
Partei Namen verändert haben das ist
richtig aber im Moment dankt ihnen der
Wähler das was sie da jetzt gerade
aufzählten als das Maßnahmen aus der
letzten Zeit ja eigentlich nicht sie
haben in den Umfragen haben sie ganz
schön nachgelassen seit der
Bundestagswahl der beliebteste Politiker
der SPD ist auch nicht oder Scholz der
Kanzler ausgerechnet borus Pistorius der
vor all den Rüstung kauft das ist jetzt
auch kein genuin sozialdemokratisches
Thema naja sie sprechen Umfragen an aber
in Bremen haben wir die Wahl gewonnen
wir stellen doch weiterhin eben den
Regierungschef und das ist mir ganz
wichtig und ich sehe auch durchaus gute
Chancen für Hessen nennt sie Phaser
macht eine hervorragende Politik und am
Ende entscheiden nicht diese Umfragen
sondern die Wählerinnen und Wähler wenn
sie sich angucken welches personelle
Angebot sie haben und Olaf Scholz ist
derjenige der dieses Land gut durch
einen nicht gerade wenig schwere Zeit
führt er schafft internationale
Herausforderung aber ist eben auch
bereits in dieser Koalition ein Gesicht
zu geben aber eben auch Inhalt wenn sie
sagen internationale Herausforderung die
größte die ist offensichtlich mit dem
Ukraine kriegt es ist nicht irgendwie
eine Ironie der Geschichte das nun der
SPD quasi kaum dass sie endlich mal
wieder einen Kanzler stellt die Agenda
zerschossen wird ausgerechnet von
Russland ausgerechnet von put das von
der von so vielen Sozialdemokraten
hofiert wurde nun wir nehmen uns jeder
Herausforderung an das ist ja auch der
Unterschied dass einige nach Belieben
handeln wir handeln nicht nach Belieben
sondern wir stellen uns der
Verantwortung Wissen um die Situation
insbesondere von Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern und ihrer Familien wissen
aber auch dass das was eben auch
Friedenspolitik für die
Sozialdemokratische Partei ist mehr als
das was in der Vergangenheit gewesen ist
jetzt macht der Bundeskanzler klar wir
brauchen eine Unterstützung für die
Ukraine wir brauchen aber auf der
anderen Seite auch Gesprächskontakte zu
den Ländern die den Krieg er
offensichtlich ein bisschen anders sehen
und das ist gut das ist klug und das
kann nur ein souveräner Sozialdemokrat
tun bei den Festtag reden heute wurde
eine sozialdemokratischer Kanzler gar
nicht mehr erwähnt er hat Schröder
ich habe überhaupt nicht aus diesen
Festlichkeiten heraus gehört dass man
irgendwen nicht erwähnt sondern wir
haben eine große Tradition 160 Jahre da
kann ich jeder Name auch noch vorgelesen
werden sondern es geht bei uns Kanzlerin
ehemalige kann jeder Name aber man muss
letztlich eben darauf achten dass wir
die Geschichte würdigen und nicht
einzelne Personen benennen sondern wir
bestehen aus einer Mitgliederpartei über
400.000 und das macht stolz und deswegen
sage ich auch ganz klar viele bei uns
achten nicht sozusagen auf ihre eigenen
Befindlichkeiten sondern das was sie mit
der Sozialdemokratischen Partei auch
erreicht erreichen sagt der
Fraktionsvorsitzende dieser Partei danke
Ihnen Herr Mütze nicht herzlichen Dank
für die Einladung
das Interview haben wir vor zwei Stunden
geführt und ja eigentlich ist für die
Sozialdemokraten heute ein Feiertag den
sie sich vom Koalitionsstreit nicht
gänzlich verderben lassen wollen 160
Jahre SPD es gibt weltweit nur wenige
Parteien die auf einer so lange
Gründungsgeschichte zurückblicken können
das ist ihr Stolz aber manchmal auch
ihre Last etwa wenn alte Mythen den
Blick verstellten wie in der
Russlandpolitik oder wenn sie immer
wieder mit sich selbst haderte im
Zwiespalt zwischen idealistischer
programmpartei und pragmatischer
Regierungsparteien derzeit dominiert
harmonischer Pragmatismus wie Lars
wohnsack auch beim offiziellen
Geburtstagsfest im Willy Brandhaus
beobachtete
selbst heute noch wirkt das Bild
irgendwie ungewöhnlich zwei
Parteivorsitzende ein Bundeskanzler und
kein Streit das war nicht immer so in
der SPD die Sozialdemokraten haben in
ihren 160 Jahren einige heuteungen
vornehmen müssen zu denen sie auch heute
noch stehen wir sind oftmals nicht die
schrillste nicht die lauteste auch nicht
die hipste Partei Brücken in die
Gesellschaft zu bauen ist uns wichtiger
als seine reißerische Überschrift wir
setzen uns dafür ein dass diejenigen
gehört und gesehen werden die nicht die
stärksten und kraftvollsten in dieser
Gesellschaft sind und genau dafür müssen
wir uns nicht schämen gegründet 1863 als
Arbeiter und Bildungsverein ruft nach
Abdankung des Kaisers ein sozial
Demokrat die erste deutsche Republik aus
verfolgt und im Untergrund in der
Nazizeit als einzige Partei hat die SPD
gegen Hitlers Ermächtigungsgesetz
gestimmt
die Ehre nicht Willy Brandt wird 1969
erster sozialdemokratischer
Bundeskanzler wir wollen mehr Demokratie
wagen ihm folgen Helmut Schmidt 16 Jahre
Opposition Gerhard Schröder und nach
noch mal 16 Jahren Olaf Scholz eine
vergleichbare Geschichte kann keine
andere Partei in Deutschland vorweisen
wir haben allen Grund stolz auf unsere
Geschichte zu sein
Freiheit Gerechtigkeit und Solidarität
alte sozialdemokratische Grundwerte für
die SPD heute so aktuell wie zu Willy
brandtszeiten wir kämpfen für ein gutes
Leben für alle Menschen ein Leben in dem
dein Weg nicht davon abhängt wo du oder
wo da der Eltern herkommen oder welches
Einkommen sie haben in dem nicht deine
Hautfarbe oder dein geschlech darüber
entscheidet was du tun kannst indem es
keine Rolle spielt was du glaubst wie du
lebst wen du liebst einer war heute
nicht geladen Gerhard Schröder dessen
Hinterlassenschaften Hartz IV und
Russland Nähe hat die SPD längst
korrigiert doch das Regieren in der
Ampel ist schwieriger als gedacht auf
die Partei warten noch harte Zeiten die
SPD ist noch lange nicht am Ende lasst
uns mit Zuversicht und Optimismus
mit Visionen und Wirklichkeit in die
nächsten Jahre gehen die
Sozialdemokratie wird gebraucht
abschlussbild mit Kanzler auch wenn die
Umfragewerte derzeit eher mau sind der
ältesten deutschen Partei ging es schon
deutlich schlechter als in diesen Tagen
wenn es eine koordinierte Aktion war
dann war es eine Art
Himmelfahrtskommando was
paramilitärische Gruppen da auf
russischen Territorium ausführten sie
überrannten russische Grenzposten
drangen in die Region Belgrad ein und
besetzten mehrere Dörfer Russland
behauptet es habe diese Attacke
inzwischen zurückgeschlagen aber der
Schock darüber dass so etwas überhaupt
möglich war ist den Russen anzumerken
neben der psychologischen Wirkung hat
diese Aktion auch noch eine politische
Dimension in der Inszenierung erinnert
das Ganze daran die 2014 die Russen in
die Ostukraine eindrang mit Uniformen
ohne Hoheitsabzeichen und der Erklärung
und führe einen Freiheitskampf
und Christiane Hoffmann berichten
mein Vater hat mir gesagt ich soll
Traktorfahrer werden Scheiße bin ich
aber nicht ich bin Soldat geworden
diese Aufnahmen sollen aus Belgorod
stammen angeblich kämpfen gleich zwei
russische Gruppierungen in Russland um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen und Putin zu
stürzen
wir wollen dass unsere Kinder in Frieden
aufwachsen um reisen um studieren zu
können und einfach glücklich zu sein in
einem freien Land aber dafür gibt es
keinen Platz in Putins Russland das
verrottet ist durch Korruption Lügen
Zensur Einschränkungen und Unterdrückung
ja von beiden Organisationen hat man
schon in der Vergangenheit gehört es gab
entgleiste Züge es gab Anschläge
Anschläge auf Bahnschienen auf
Gleisanlagen in der in Russland und es
sind auch immer wieder Züge entgleist
also das scheint hinter den Kulissen in
Russland eine Art gewaltsame
Widerstandsbewegung zu operieren
acht Menschen sollen in der
westrorischen Region Belgorod bei den
Anschlägen verletzt worden sein diese
Bilder sollen Evakuierungen zeigen ob
sie echt sind kann nicht mit Sicherheit
gesagt werden
während Russland ukrainische
sabotagegruppen für die Anschläge
verantwortlich macht weist selenskis
Berater podoljak die Verantwortung
seines Landes für die Anschläge schon
fast genüsslich zurück die Ukraine
beobachtet die Vorkommnisse in Belgorod
mit Interesse und studiert die Situation
hat aber nichts damit zu tun
es geht aus meiner Sicht in erster Linie
darum Verwirrung zu stiften und Russland
zu blamieren und wenn man sich die
Bilder der letzten beiden Tage anguckt
dann ist das eindeutig auch gelungen das
ist sehr peinlich für Russland was da
passiert ein weiteres Ziel liegt auf der
Hand russische Streitkräfte von der
Kriegsfront abzuziehen um ihre Heimat zu
verteidigen dieser Plan ist heute
aufgegangen
zumindest dürften solche Nadelstiche der
ukrainischen Gegenoffensive zu Pass
kommen davon gibt es seit Wochen ja
viele wir haben es gerade gehört
russische Treibstofflager die in die
Luft fliegen Güterzüge die entgleisen
truppenstandorte die beschossen werden
am Ende aber wird es wesentlich darauf
ankommen wie viele und welche Waffen die
Ukraine zur Verfügung hat über den
Verlauf dieses Krieges wird insofern
wesentlich in den Hauptstädten der NATO
und EU-Länder entschieden heute berieten
die eu-verteidigungsminister in Brüssel
davon berichtet Isabel Schäfers
im November eskortierten diese
polnischen f16-piloten ihre
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft jetzt sollen
ukrainische Soldaten in den Kampfjets
trainiert werden laut dem
EU-Außenbeauftragten heute morgen hat
die Ausbildung bereits begonnen in Polen
z.B
polnische Verteidigungsminister muss am
Nachmittag etwas bremsen
aber wir sind natürlich bereit mit der
Ausbildung zu beginnen
klar wird jedenfalls auch in Brüssel ist
Dynamik in die Diskussion über die
Ausbildung von F16 Piloten gekommen seit
die USA als Herkunftsland grünes Licht
gegeben haben das bedeutet dass wir
jetzt so schnell wie möglich mit der
Ausbildung beginnen werden und bis zur
Lieferung von Flugzeugen wird es noch
etwas dauern das ist erst der nächste
Schritt
wäre
Deutschland hatte sich bisher aus der
Diskussion weitestgehend rausgehalten
mit dem Verweis man selbst verfüge über
keine F16 Kampfjets doch heute schließt
der deutsche Verteidigungsminister eine
Unterstützung nicht mehr aus wie ein
paar Möglichkeiten die es theoretisch
geben könnte die prüfen wir gerade und
dann werden wir sagen ob wir diesen
Beitrag leisten können und wollen
Deutschland könnte bei dem Aufbau
vielleicht der Infrastruktur helfen und
ansonsten versuchen die Logistik so weit
es geht mit Sicherheit zu stellen aber
es ist in der Tat so dass Deutschland
zumindest wenn es um den speziellen
Typen F16 geht keine großen Beiträge
leisten kann zu einem anderen Ziel
sollen alle EU-Staaten beitragen mehr
Munition für die Ukraine eine Million
Geschosse in zwölf Monaten das war die
Zusage heute die Meldung eines
teilerfolgs
220.000 Artilleriegeschosse wurden
bereits an die Ukraine geliefert die
Mitgliedstaaten die geliefert haben
wollen die Kosten jetzt aus EU-Mitteln
ersetzt bekommen
doch die EU-Gelder für die militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine sind
aufgebraucht und Ungarn blockiert einer
Aufstockung und auch Produktions
Engpässe lassen immer wieder daran
zweifeln ob die EU ihre Zusage einhalten
kann es ist immer wichtig über neue
Unterstützungsmöglichkeiten zu
diskutieren Flugzeuge Panzer
Luftabwehrsysteme aber genauso wichtig
oder vielleicht sogar noch wichtiger ist
es dafür zu sorgen dass alle Systeme die
sich bereits in der Ukraine befinden so
arbeiten und funktionieren wie sie
sollen und dafür brauchen sie Munition
und Treibstoff
könnte auch heißen der Wille ist da
Europa will die Ukraine unterstützen
aber an einer zügigen Umsetzung hapert
es weiter
[Musik]
mit anderen Nachrichten des Tages
der Präsident des Bundeskriminalamtes
Münch und die Missbrauchsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Klaus haben heute Zahlen
zu sexueller Gewalt an Kindern und
Jugendlichen vorgestellt 48
Opfer täglich registriert die
polizeiliche Kriminalstatistik im
Durchschnitt für 2022 es waren ähnlich
viele wie 2021 17.437
Opfer im vergangenen Jahr weiter
gestiegen ist laut München die Zahl der
erfasst missbrauchsdarstellungen im
Internet auf mehr als
42.000 die Dunkelziffer gilt dabei
weiterhin als hoch
ein halbes Jahr nach einer großrat sehr
gegen eine reichsbürgergruppe wurden
jetzt drei weitere mutmaßliche
Mitglieder festgenommen die zwei Männer
und eine Frau sind laut
Bundesanwaltschaft seit heute Nachmittag
in Untersuchungshaft sie sollen zu der
Gruppe um den Frankfurter Geschäftsmann
Heinrich Prinz Reus gehören der seit
Dezember in Haft ist der Gruppe wird
vorgeworfen einen gewaltsamen Umsturz
des politischen Systems in Deutschland
geplant zu haben
der Bundestag will voraussichtlich noch
in dieser Woche die pflege-reform
verabschieden und nun gibt es in der
Ampelkoalition offenbar auch eine
Verständigung bei der Entlastung für
pflegende Angehörige sie sollen ein
flexibel nutzbares Budget bekommen mit
dem sie etwa eine pflegefinanzieren
können wenn sie eine Auszeit nehmen in
der Reform vorgesehen ist auch eine
Anhebung des Beitragssatzes zur
Pflegeversicherung um mindestens
0,35% Punkte
die rund 55.000 Ärztinnen und Ärzte
kommunaler Kliniken mit Ausnahme von
Berlin erhalten ab Juli 8,8% mehr Gehalt
darauf haben sich der Marburger Bund und
die Vereinigung der kommunalen
Arbeitgeberverbände geeinigt hinzukommen
inflationsausgleichszahlungen von
insgesamt
2500 Euro und um ihren Forderungen
Nachdruck zu verleihen hatten die
Ärztinnen und Ärzte in den vergangenen
Wochen mehrfach die Arbeit niedergelegt
die Bundesregierung hat ihr Ziel
jährlich 400.000 neue Wohnungen zu bauen
im vergangenen Jahr deutlich verfehlt
das geht aus aktuellen Zahlen der
Statistischen Bundesamtes hervor demnach
konnten 2022 trotz seines leichten
Anstiegs gegenüber dem Vorjahr nur gut
295.000 Wohnungen fertiggestellt werden
große Probleme bereiteten die massiv
gestiegenen Bau und Energiekosten zudem
fehlten Fachkräfte und beim benötigten
Material gab es Lieferengpässe
wer fiel mit der Bahn unterwegs ist oder
jetzt im Sommer Urlaubsreisen per Bahn
geplant hat muss in diesen Tagen
hoffnungsvoll nach Fulda blicken dort
sitzen sich Bahn AG und Eisenbahner
Gewerkschaft gegenüber drei ergebnislose
Runden im Tarifstreit liegen bereits
hinter ihnen Isabel de lavega beobachtet
die Verhandlungen
zum vierten Mal kommen sie in diesen
Tarifstreit zusammen die Vertreter der
Gewerkschaften ein bisschen
hemdsärmliger die Arbeitgeberseite
gegenüber und auch nach zwei waren
streikt sie das Land halb lahm legten
will man nicht nachgeben noch einmal
drohen sie den Bahn Managern wenn wir
verspüren dass der Arbeitgeber erneut
nicht die konstruktive Verhandlung am
Tisch will wir haben das ja schon einmal
hinter uns auch ihren Fulda wo nicht wir
abgerissen sondern eine Arbeitgeber
abgereist ist nach bereits einem Tag
dann drohen natürlich auch erneute
Warnstreiks bis hin auch zu einer
möglichen Abstimmung mit dann
unbefristeten Streits Reinigungskräfte
oder Security Mitarbeiter die Bahn hat
für die unteren Lohngruppen ihr
angeboten nachgebessert und will den
Mindestlohn in der Tarif Tabelle
festschreiben vorher kamen die 12 €
teilweise nur über Zuschläge zusammen
die EVG aber forderten mehr 12%
Lohnsteigerung mindestens aber 650 €.
die Bahn bietet 10% für unteren und 8%
für die oberen Lohngruppen dazu eine
Einmalzahlung von
2.850 Euro außerdem solle alles schon
für 2023 gelten die Bahn will erst 2024
mehr zahlen müssen der Tarifkonflikt ist
ungewöhnlich hart aus strategischen
Gründen Experten meinen dass die EVG
viele Mitglieder verloren hat in den
letzten Jahren und sich möglicherweise
so ein bisschen an dem Modell wäre die
orientiert wäre die hat ja im
öffentlichen Dienst massiv Warnstreiks
organisiert in diesem Frühjahr und dabei
90.000 Neueintritte gewonnen und das ist
so ein bisschen ein Modell dass zur
Nachahmung ja sozusagen provoziert und
die Gewerkschaft will hinter der
schlagkräftigen GDL nicht zurück bleiben
die EVG steht im Konkurrenzkampf mit der
GDL der Lokführergewerkschaft die
verhandelt erst im Herbst und die EVG
will natürlich nicht wieder wie bei den
letzten Tarifverhandlungen von der GDL
übertrumpft werden und doch auch die
Bahn steht unter Druck weitere Streiks
treten den Konzern zur Sommerreisezeit
besonders hart ein bisschen Eigenlob
soll helfen die Stimmung aufzubessern
aber wir haben mit der Tat uns bereits
sehr gestreckt und haben das größte
Angebot der Bahn vorgelegt das geht um
Anerkennung der Leistungen und die sind
wirklich großartig das wissen wir auch
und deswegen haben wir auch unsere
Mitarbeitenden verdient dass wir zu
guten Ergebnissen kommen drei Tage
wollen sie sich nehmen das ist zumindest
ein Zeichen dass man diesmal zu einem
Ergebnis kommen möchte
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Hans mit einem anderen
Wirtschaftsthema bei bundeswirtschafts-
und klimaschutzminister Habeck gab es
heute einen windkraft-gipfel mit
Vertreterinnen und Vertretern von Bund
Ländern und Energiebranche habe ich will
die Windenergie vorantreiben weil er
realer was ist konkret vorgesehen er hat
so einiges vor Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck um es auf einen Nenner zu
bringen mehr Fläche weniger Bürokratie
außerdem möchte er die heimische
Windindustrie stärken und die Forschung
fördern die Pläne sind ziemlich
ehrgeizig habe ich will den Ausbau
nämlich vervierfachen und er sieht schon
erste Fortschritte im vergangenen Jahr
sei der Ausbau um 30% gegenüber dem
Vorjahr gestiegen und dieses Jahr soll
das Plus noch größer werden um ein
höheres Tempo bei der Windkraft zu
erreichen will habe mehr Flächen
bereitstellen gezielt Fachkräfte
anwerben und Genehmigungsverfahren
Beschleunigung
die Genehmigungen sind sozusagen die
Achillesferse und zwar nicht nur die
Erlaubnis für die Windparks sondern auch
die Genehmigungen für die
Schwertransporte auf der Straße die die
windradteile zu ihrem Bestimmungsort
bringen manchmal dauert es Monate bis so
eine Fahrt genehmigt wird auch sind
Spediteure schwer zu finden weil sich
der Job kaum für sie rechnet für die
Bundesregierung ist die Windenergie
Schlüsseltechnologie um ihre Klimaziele
zu erreichen doch bis es so weit ist
wird sie noch an einigen Stellschrauben
drehen müssen
vielen Dank
beide Eishockey-Weltmeisterschaft steht
das deutsche Team im Viertelfinale und
trifft dort auf die Schweiz zum
Vorrundenabschluss heute gab es für die
deutsche Mannschaft einen 5 zu 0 Sieg
gegen Frankreich
es ist der vierte Sieg nacheinander
schon nach vier Minuten führt das
DEB-Team durch Alexander ehlwald
stachowiakballons und übersichtbehält
kurios das 2:0 durch den linken Fuß von
tiffels das zählt weil ohne kickbewegung
angeschossen von Peter und dieser GG
avanciert mit seinem vierten Tor bei
dieser WM zum Top Scorer im deutschen
Team das optimistisch ins Viertelfinale
geht die Schweizer sagen selber das ist
vielleicht die beste Mannschaft diese je
auf einen Weltmeisterschaft schicken
konnten ich will eine sehr starke
Vorrunde für heute Niederberger das
erste zu Nullspiel dieser WM kein
schlechtes Omen
das war von uns mit der Anstalt geht es
gleich weiter und um 0920 meldet sich
dann Gundula Gause mit unserem heutigen
Update
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend und herzlich willkommen
zum Wetter richtig kühle Luft hat uns
jetzt geflutet und die Gewitter Luft
verdrängt wir erwarten morgen den
kühlsten Tag der Woche mit Temperaturen
um 15 Grad während es im Norden in
Finnland zum Beispiel noch Temperaturen
um 25 Grad gibt das ganze liegt an einem
Kaltlufttropfen so nennen wir dieses
kleine Höhentief dass ich jetzt vom
tiefen Druck im Norden abspaltet und
genau über uns hinweg zieht und so wird
das morgen eben auch eine kühle Nacht
bei Aufklaren sinken die Werte in den
Mittelgebirgen auf zwei Grad und dann
ist auch wieder Boden Frost möglich
unter den Wolken da bleibt es bei 8 bis
13 Grad das ist zum einen an den Alpen
der Fall da gibt's auch anfangs noch die
gewittrigen Schauer auch in den Küsten
sind viele Wolken unterwegs und der noch
lebhafte nord-westwind bringen neue
Schauer und diese Schauer und auch die
dichten Wolken kommen dann morgen im
Tagesverlauf weiter Richtung Mitte voran
allzu viel fällt aber nicht raus und
später kommt direkt an den Küsten und im
Nordosten auch wieder etwas die Sonne
raus der Wind lässt im Vergleich zu
heute etwas nach am meisten Sonne gibt
es morgen aber in den südwestlichen
Landesteilen direkt an den Alpen bleiben
die showerwolken da ist dann nachmittags
auch mal ein kräftiges Gewitter möglich
und die kühle Luft ist eben überall
angekommen 13 Grad nur in den höheren
Berglagen am Rhein mit Sonne immerhin
noch mal 20 Grad ja und diese Schauer an
den Alpen bleiben uns jetzt erstmal auch
noch erhalten es setzt sich aber doch
immer mehr die Sonne durch und am
Samstag vor Pfingsten da sind dann
immerhin schon wieder 15 bis 24 Grad
möglich das war es von uns tschüss